we're joined now from gas go by
Scotland's first minister and the leader
of the SNP at liquid sturgeon and to
discuss this film and more thank you
very much for being with us this morning
and welcome I just wanted to start on
the film from east rain for sure because
I spoke to a lot of people who voted for
the Conservatives last time they don't
like the brexit policy he voted for
labour last time but they're not
convinced by Jeremy Corbyn this is a
seat of course where people voted to
remain in the Union in the independence
referendum I just wonder if you're
worried that by putting independence at
the heart of this election you might be
putting off some of these voters who are
looking for an alternative but don't
want to see an independent Scotland no
I'm not and frankly there's no evidence
of that in opinion polls in Scotland I
think people are very clear about the
reasons for voting SNP firstly if you
don't want Boris Johnson to win a
majority in this election then the SNP
is of the main Challenger and all of
these Tory held seats including Eastern
for sure so vote SNP to stop Boris
Johnson if you want to escape brexit the
SNP has been the most consistently Pro
remain party in Scotland so that's a
vote to escape the mess of breaks and
then yes of course if you vote SNP
you're voting to put Scotland's future
into Scotland's hands now whether you
support independent sort of poison
dependence on ardent yet decided on
independence what you're voting for is
the proposition that it should be people
in Scotland to make the decisions about
our future not politicians at
Westminster like Boris Johnson and my
experience of this election of the way I
take nothing for granted there's a long
way to go is that that message is
resonating very strongly in every part
of the country well not long to find out
if how our that message is yes and we
are potentially of course you know
waiting for the result we are where we
are watching without the election if
there is a hung parliament I'm
interested to know what do the snps red
lines in any discussions you have with
other parties about offering them away
into number 10 well first of all a hung
parliament with the SNP holding the
balance of power would give Scotland
maximum influence so that would be a
pretty good outcome I think in terms of
making sure Scotland's voices
my first red line is that I would never
ever put Boris Johnson into Downing
Street because I've seen up close and
over too many years the damage
Conservative government's do to the kind
of communities I grew up in in terms of
supporting a minority labor government
have been clear that we wouldn't have a
formal coalition it would be a less
formal arrangement and yes of course I
would expect Jeremy Corbyn and the
Labour Party to respect Scotland right
to choose our own future but there are
other matters that I would want to
progress as well stopping brakes
obviously but a real end to austerity
until such time to Scotland as
independent devolution of powers over
migration and employment so that we can
protect what creates for example an end
to the misery of universal credit and
welfare cuts and the rape clause and to
child cap better pensions so these are
the policies progressive policies that I
think resonates strongly in Scotland but
actually raisin he's strongly with many
people right across the UK in 2015 you
said that scrapping trident Britain's
nuclear deterrent would also be a
redline in any discussions is that the
same general yeah absolutely that's
another matter that we would we would
absolutely be firm about and and that's
tied if you like to some of these other
policies because you know I'll be very
cleared I have a moral objection to
weapons of mass destruction unlike Joe
Swanson I wouldn't be prepared to press
a nuclear button that would kill
potentially millions tens of millions of
people but there's also the opportunity
costs of Trident the billions tens of
billions of pounds that are required to
renew Trident in my view are better
spent on stronger conventional defence
that is more effective to protect our
country but also on hospitals and
schools and better Social Security
provision and these are the choices that
we should be thinking very carefully
about and you know if the SNP is in that
position of influence then these are
absolutely the kind of policies that we
will pursue so just to be crystal clear
on this scrapping Trident would be a
redline in any discussions with labour
that you may have
I was crystal clear on that I've been
campaigning
against Trident for all of my life so
yes that is absolutely a key position
that the SMP would have in any
discussions about supporting and
minority labor government and you say
that you want more devolution of powers
as well and the SMP Conference voted to
decriminalize controlled drugs there's
that the kind of thing that you won't
like to see the bold in these
discussions if as you say it would give
Scotland such influence yes we would
want to power over drugs law to be
devolved obviously it would then be up
to Scottish Parliament to decide how
exactly to use that power one of the
issues that we have been pushing forward
and have had discussions so far on
successful discussions with Westminster
is to have the power to allow Glasgow
City Council for example to establish
what's called a safe consumption
facility to try to reduce the harms
associated with drug use and to help us
along with all of the other things we're
doing to reduce the death toll from drug
misuse so these are absolutely all
things we would want to progress and
what we're doing here I think in this
discussion is illustrating just how much
more powerful Scotland's position would
be if we were in that position so but
the first step in that is to deny Boris
Johnson a majority and gone back to
where we started and seeks like he
trained for sure whether you voted SNP
in the passed a law if you voted labour
on Lib Dem or whoever if you want to
stop Boris Johnson then voting SNP the
main challenges in these seats is the
only way to do that we heard from John
McDonald a little earlier in the program
and I asked him about the idea of the
Scottish independence referendum he said
it wouldn't be something that a Labour
government would grant in the first two
to three years is that an acceptable
position if you were to go into these
negotiations and nor my position and the
one that I would expect Libra 2
respectively wanted SNP support is that
the question of if that is a
independence referendum and the timing
of that is down to the Scottish
Parliament to decide not Westminster but
I'd I'd ask people to consider this and
you know sort of think ourselves into
the 13th of December and Liebherr are in
a position against what all the opinion
polls might be suggesting to form a
minority government and they need the
support of the SNP are they really gonna
turn their back on at the chance to stop
posterity to stop welfare
let's get rid of universal credit just
because the what to block the rate of
the Scottish people to decide their own
future and argue over the a couple of
years I mean I think the reason Jeremy
Corbyn is getting himself into a mess on
this with his position changing all the
time is actually he knows within himself
that the only democratically defensible
position here is to see it for him he
might oppose independence he might not
want there to be another referendum but
actually it's not for Westminster to
decide these things it's for the
Scottish people through their
democratically elected Scottish
Parliament to decide these things I
think that's the position Jeremy Corbyn
knows is Ray and I don't think he's
going to turn his back on all of these
other things he wants to do as with a
Labour government just because he's so
determined to block the rate of the
Scottish Parliament to decide the timing
of a referendum he'd previously
described Boris Johnson and Jeremy
Corbyn as completely and utterly useless
now you've been very clear that you
wouldn't put Boris Johnson in to number
10 so why would you help put Jeremy
Corbyn into a number 10 if you think
he's completely in utterly useless well
Sophie I mean I don't think I'm telling
anybody anything that they haven't heard
me say before neither of these guys
would be my choice as as Prime Minister
and I've made my views clear and Boris
Johnson I wouldn't choose Jeremy Corbyn
as leader of the Labour Party but I
don't get to choose the leader of the
Labour Party and if we are in a position
of a hung parliament with the SNP
holding the balance of power on a good
position as we've just been talking
about
then sometimes you have to be prepared
to choose between the devil and the deep
blue sea so it's not my choice but you
have to choose what you think you can
make the most progress and get the the
most progress and the kind of policies
priorities and values and I would say to
people and there are many of them in
Scotland as across the rest of the UK
who have real concerns about Jeremy
Corbyn then better to have the SNP in
there keeping them on the right track or
a better track than have them without
that so you know whatever way you look
at they're scaling SNP MPs and they are
stopping bodies towards and getting a
majority and making sure the right
policies priorities and values are to
the fore is the best way to vote in this
election
now just finally transparency in
politics is of course really important
and now being claims recently that you
avoid using the Scottish government
email system and the officials may also
be using private emails and perhaps
using your SMP address or private
addresses which of course would
potentially avoid scrutiny and Freedom
of Information requests is that right no
it's not it's emphatically not the case
I mean there's been a lot of nonsense
talks about this I do government
business in exactly the same way as my
predecessors have done it the same way
government ministers have done it for a
long long time I think the the current
guidance around all of this dates back
to 2004 or five I've never changed at
any government business I do is
subjected to Freedom of Information
legislation regardless of the platform
that I do and so you know there's been a
lot of tempts to suggest that there is
something untoward here but absolutely
fact interestingly the reason that my
opponents in Scotland nor about emails
from her and SNP addresses because they
were released under Freedom of
Information requests so you know there
is complete transparency here and you
know what other parties are talking
about is complete enough to have
nonsense I mean you say that everything
is all of your communication no matter
what the platform is subjected to these
Freedom of Information requests and
you've also said that you make
handwritten notes sometimes and rather
than doing everything well let me
explain because ministers if you talk to
a UK government Minister what you get
boxey's government boxes with written
paper submissions and cite and I will
write on it
yes I'm happy with that or no I'm not
happy with that or demand this bit goes
back to my private office my private
office at take my handwritten note or
instruction tape that into an email and
send it back to the official that's how
it gets disseminated within the civil
service and that's how government
business has been done for as far back
as I can remember the idea that this is
some kin a system I have introduced is
just ridiculous and in a government
minister hearing what I've just
described we'll know that that's exactly
how they do government business so what
happens to the notes after us because I
think my understanding is that say for
example Boris Johnson's mates are
retained because I mean in September it
was the handwritten note from the Prime
but it showed that he degrade as a fan
Parliament yep yeah so this is a bit I
told you about two thousand four or five
that the guidance on at record-keeping
which is sent to the registers of
Scotland every year whether it's the
electronic copy of the note that is care
either than the handwritten copy of the
note that's not a system I have
introduced that's the system that was
introduced actually before there was
even an SNP government in Scotland so I
haven't changed it in any way I do it
the way it's been done since that far
back so there is no there is nothing
here that is different to how others
have done government business and your
the the record of that the electronic
record of that is open to Freedom of
Information and you know there is a lot
of information released from the
Scottish government as from the UK
government and the idea that that is not
completely transparent is just nonsense
okay Nicola Sturgeon thank you very much
you can see quite a lot of em Rankin
boots there behind you looking forward
to getting back to those at the election
campaign I always look forward to
getting back to my boots Nicola Sturgeon
thank you very much for being on the
program today thank you